jim is in pittsburgh
hi jim welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey honored to be on nice to talk with
you and chris you too sir how can we
help
so at the uh right around the end of
last year dave my wife and i finished
paying
ninety seven thousand dollars of debt
way to go
and yeah thank you it took about ten
months
it wasn't it was our intention to come
down and do the screen but uh
you know life happens coronavirus
happens so
uh what we're looking at now though is
we're looking at
kind of what to do next and about a year
from now we have the potential of having
a down payment saved for about a 200
000 house but i'm kind of really not
interested in getting back
into debt and we had we're throwing
around the idea of
actually waiting five years investing
that money and then maybe
five or six years from now having the
money to spend cash
on perhaps a 300 000 house i just wanted
to get your thoughts on that
how old are you 28.
it's a great plan i love the plan i like
the 100
down plan and let me let me predict for
you what will happen
it will happen 25 sooner than you think
you're going to get impatient and you're
going to save more aggressively like
when you're getting out of debt
because you're going to get a little bit
of house fever along the way and you're
gonna pile up some cash and you're gonna
do it in four years instead of six
but that's wonderful great i think that
and also your income will usually come
up during that period of time
too and now that you have a solid fixed
goal
you're going to be 32 33 years old and
paying cash for a house that's my
prediction
because i've watched people do this a
bunch over the last 30 years
and i think it's a wonderful plan
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that
you don't think there's any risk of
having that money in
some good performing mutual funds five
or six years from now
97 of the consecutive five year periods
any particular five years start on in a
year and go five years
since the stock market began have made
money
when you don't leave it alone five years
the probability goes up that you will
lose some money
but um i and i you know there's no pr
there's no perfect formula you don't
know
but the historical indicators are that
if you leave it alone at least
five years you're gonna make some money
yeah
and jim i think you all zeroing in on
this and understanding
exactly how much you're saving each
month you know
uh i wouldn't open up um you know you
could
you could park the money in the in the
in the in your money market account if
it's going to be
three years or less other than that you
could definitely take a look at
investing it
you got some of it investing somebody's
using an index fund with no no
commissions on it doing no load fund
that's what i do when i'm parking money
short term
because here's the thing the money that
you have for the house is not going to
be due to the growth of the investment
it's going to be due to what you put in
there
you're not you've not got it invested
long enough for compound interest to
really kick in and be magical
so what would you recommend investing it
in that um
i probably uh given that this is a
a relatively large portion of your total
net worth
and it's a big hairy deal emotionally i
probably would put fifty percent of it
into a money market and fifty percent of
it into an index fund
and that way the money market's not
going to make anything it's not going to
lose anything so you got that as kind of
your stable piece of the equation
yeah the other one maybe is going to
make a little and you're not going to
feel so bad about making nothing
you know but that index fund it could go
up it could go down
but if it's if there's a hundred
thousand or let's say if there's 150
000 out of the 300
000 that you have saved when you get
ready to buy a house in the index fund
if it were down 10
that would be unbelievable
statistically historically but if it
were
that's only fifteen thousand dollars and
it doesn't keep you from getting your
house
which by the way the stock market is
down stock market is down ten 10
over a five-year period of time
your house is going to be on sale the
property you're looking at is going to
be a good deal
so you know the other side of the
market's going to pick you up so you
know but that way
you're you know you're diversifying
you've got some and no risk and some in
a little risk
and even that if it lost a little bit is
not going to keep you from hitting your
goals it's not going to
say i lost all my money in the stock
market it's not going to happen that's
not going to come up
so way to go man good goal